[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabbie HD here
and one of the trends at CES is if you
walked around long enough you would see
a bunch of TVs a bunch of VR headsets
and a bunch of drunk and it wasn't
always this way you know drones have
come a long way in the past couple years
since we first started messing with them
this DJI and Matic Pro that came out a
couple months ago despite a couple of
issues that has had pretty much
represents the pinnacle of consumer
drones and how far they've come and in
just a couple of hours of playing with
one I can pretty quickly see why so all
the innovation in quad copters and tiny
cameras and stabilization gimble's
propellers and sensors and communication
technology all of that stuff comes
together to make this badass little
thousand dollar toy and it's a lot of
fun to play with as it should be so I've
always had a sort of basic staple for I
guess when new smartphones come out how
they can be complete you know good
display good battery good camera etc
well for a drone basically what I'm
looking for is good performance good
controls and then of course a good
camera so first of all the drone itself
on the Maverick Pro it's super small
that's kind of what it's known for even
compared to other drones from DJI and
others so many other drones with cameras
acquire like their own carrying case or
box because they're too big to travel
with otherwise the Mavic pro is small
enough that it can fit in pretty much
any bag or a backpack or a travel bag or
even a big enough jacket pocket if you
wanted to thanks to the folding design
so it's definitely small and then
performance wise it happens to be right
up there with the best you never really
find yourself limited by the speed or
acceleration or stability you can use it
up to four miles away and basically the
biggest challenge there when keeping it
so far away is just keeping an eye on it
on the horizon
keeping your orientation so you can fly
it back how the controller is actually
pretty clever it's part drone controls
and part video controls and they put a
lot of that power on your smartphone so
you grab the DJI app for Android or iOS
and clip your phone in there and then it
gives you recording controls for the
camera and then all kinds of information
for when the drone is on plus the top
part of controller itself is just your
typical joystick controller so going up
down side side for
backward turning all that now fun fact
the Matic Pro has a 38 hundred million
power battery that you can remove so not
really that much bigger than the
smartphone you might be watching us on
but that battery can power the drone for
a 25 minute flight time before it starts
wanting to come home and land and that
might not seem like that much at first
but that's actually way on the upper end
of longer drone flight times on a single
battery and the battery is recharged
pretty quickly too so basically if you
want to fly for a while you got to have
a couple batteries ready to swap out but
all this to me is kind of secondary to
the main reason I would get a drone
which is having a camera in the air so
the Mavic Pro has a built in 4k 30fps
camera on a gimbal and this is kind of
what DJI does best so they're great with
stabilization of larger cameras that
translates pretty well here too to the
gimbal on the Mavic Pro and the camera
itself is so small that it's basically a
smartphone sized camera sensor with a
super wide lens but that's actually not
a bad thing at all because you already
know how good smartphone cameras have
gotten in the past couple years so
having a camera too small is no problem
for 99% of uses so you can imagine like
a galaxy s7 edge or an iphone 7 camera
up there in the sky and this is even a
review I just messed around with flying
this thing for a couple of hours I
didn't mess with focus points or a
manual mode I was basically just getting
my feet wet with flying I took it out a
beginner mode but the video stuff was in
Auto but it immediately showed its
potential as a video tool I just turned
it on and took it in the air and was
immediately getting shots that obviously
you can't get with any other camera or
tool and sure there are other bigger
drones I can take you know GoPros and
even larger cameras up in the air those
exist but obviously those aren't going
to fit in the backpack or be able to go
with you in a bunch of places so we got
the zooming out of Google Maps looking
shot which is actually one of my
favorites the first couple meters look
like you could maybe pull it off with a
big in of jib but then obviously as you
keep zooming it becomes pretty obvious
this camera is not connected to the
ground
we got the rising up the side of a cliff
to reveal a mile score city shot this is
Hoboken so for those of you who know how
Wendy can be up here on the cliff though
Maddock was pretty rock solid looks good
then we got the the movie opening
cityscape shot over the river of New
York City pay no attention to that disco
looking water that's just kind of the
way it looks here and all of this stuff
was pretty easy just from pointing in
the right direction and hitting record
and just doing a basic move but
shout-out to Dom from Mack mixing for
helping me shoot this dude's already a
boss with his maverick Pro and all
linked his stuff below that's why you
see multiple drones and like half these
shops is because he's out here making
movie magic and I'm just kind of messing
around on the corner trying to get a
top-down shot of a random boat worth it
though I love top-down shots but he was
able to show some even more advanced
shots on how they're possible he did
this parallax shot from right above the
water you think you know a cameraman
would have to do something crazy to get
this shot but obviously there's no
cameraman it's just a drone the Maverick
Pro also has some built-in smart
features to make some more difficult
things possible just with their contrast
based focusing so follow mode lets you
have the drone lock itself into place
and then basically turn itself and the
camera to follow you around so you can
have a follow you doing something cool
without your hands needing to be on the
controller so that could be pretty
useful and there's also a couple of
mobile follow modes what I'll follow you
in the air which you might not think
you'd need to use but trying to manually
follow myself with the drone controls is
much harder than it looks I'm pretty
good with controllers so having the
drone just lock-on to me and follow me
automatically using the software was way
too cool it's not perfect but it's
obviously way better than I would have
gotten trying to do it myself plus I
don't have to be holding the controller
so yeah drones as a video tool to me is
the most exciting part of it really cool
stuff
imagine being able to use a VR headset
and look around controlling the camera
when you move your head I mean there's
all kinds of neat possibilities that
Matic Pro has me thinking about even
thinking about stuff like new angles for
car videos that I've never been tried
before I guess all I can say is stay
tuned for that
this won't be the last time I mess with
airborne cameras this is just one of
many drone videos to come obviously
thank you very much for watching this
one
now it's Aussie has an excellent base
[Music]
yes